Particle accelerators are machines that take
electric and magnetic fields,
and use them to accelerate beams of particles to almost the speed of light.
Controlling and focusing beams like that
is a bit of a challenge,
but it we can do it, we can use them not just
for scientific research,
but also say, in hospitals to generate x-rays
and proton beams for cancer treatment,
and loads of other industries as well.
This is a very visual demonstration of how
we can control and focus particles.
It's called a Paul trap, after the inventor
Wolfgang Paul.
Imagine you're riding on a beam of particles
in an accelerator.
This saddle shape is analogous to the effect
of the magnetic field as it comes up to a
focusing magnet.
If it's too far over to one side, it'll get
pushed back to the centre.
To far to this side, it'll get pushed back
to the centre.
But, it can't focus in both directions at
once, so if I were to just let this go...
it's going to fall off.
It's unstable.
It turns out you can't focus a beam of particles
in both directions at the same time with either
a static electric or magnetic field.
But we can focus beams in an accelerator,
and the way we do it is by alternating the
gradient of the field in time.
In this demonstration, we do it by spinning
the device.
The thing to note here is we have to get the
forces right and at the right time.
For example, if I rotate this any slower,
the particle will fall off.
And it's gonna fly off quite explosively if
I drop it in when it's going any faster.
By rotating the saddle we're alternating between
focussing and defocusing effect,
which is very similar to the effect of quadrupole
magnets in an accelerator.
That's a pretty crude model of a Paul trap,
but we can use a bit more of a sophisticated
setup to look at the beam motion in accelerators
in a bit more detail.
This is a quadrupole linear Paul trap and
it has four rods on which we put an AC oscillating
potential on each opposing pair of the rods
in order to provide the focusing.
Into there, between the four rods I'm going
to place some pollen particles.
I'm just going to charge up some particles
using a Teflon wand,
which I'll charge with static electricity.
What we're looking at is a bunch of pollen
particles which are trapped by the oscillating
AC fields.
If those fields were static, the particles
would just fly off in one direction or another,
but because we're oscillating them at the
right voltage and with the right freqency,
we actually manage to set up a stable region
where the particles can remain more or less
indefinitely in the centre.
Even when they have an amplitude that's not
zero they're still stable in the centre.
So they're moving inwards and outwards but
alternating between vertical and horizontal,
so when they move outwards vertically they
move inwards horizontally.
So the way that they're oscillating back and
forth, vertically and horizontally, is very
much like the movement of the beam in the
accelerator
But it's as if we're sitting on top of the
beam as we move through it as we move through it
rather than seeing the beam move along.
So that's why it looks stationary.
Turning down either the voltage or the frequency
is like slowing down the speed of the rotating
saddle trap that we had before.
This is not just a really beautiful demonstration,
but in my research, I've actually built a more precise version of this,
trapping actual ions so we can study some
of the properties of beams in real accelerators,
and using that we can study new types of accelerators
before they've even been built.